enfin on termine en musique france gall
fait sa rentrée au zénith ce soir à
paris c'est un événement car france gall
quelques années après et toujours en
tête des hit-parades france gall au
zénith en avant-première pour antenne 2
elle l'a elle là le talent elle la
pythie gayral bien sûr une des chansons
phares du nouveau spectacle france gall
bichonner aux bémols près par michel
darget le complice depuis la déclaration
d'amour 13 musicos niveau mondial
cuivres us tambours africains guitare
super gratte avec sa halle des branches
pas la france elle assume 23 ans
carrière côté fan plus de baba cool mais
de toutes jeunes filles trans d'alcimed
dole c'est quelqu'un c'est un dieu c'est
pas vrai france gall c'est mon ami c'est
que c'est une personne qui voit qui
mange qui pleurent qui rit moi je trouve
ça se passe quelque chose hein parce que
on peut pas une morale toute sa vie de
quelqu'un ça c'est bizarre en mettant ça
veut dire tu es une star c'est vrai est
dans le vrai sens du terme
mais ce fut toujours rire qu'on cuisine
forte pour les autres
le titre il a
mais surtout ce que vient de mer et
peuvent prendre un petit peu pour dieu
par moment alors donc c'est pas mal
d'arrêter et d'aller faire son marché de
donner les enfants à l'école
c'est
et là c'est vrai que c'est une chanson
qui porte un disque qui tire un disque
parce qu'une chanson qui est évidente et
je veux dire aller coûte c'est vrai les
fortes elle est évidente cézanne c'est
autre chose c'est ce qu'on appelle une
chanson d'albums perdu au fond d'un
album mais cette chanson là m'a apporté
plus que n'importe quel autre parce
qu'elle a fait que des gens qui
s'intéressaient pas à voix se sont
arrêtés sur moi se sont attachés à ce
que je faisais c'est anne chanson
paysage une des plus belles réussites du
couple france gall michel berger deux
talents complémentaires
le résultat est là et les toiles de la
star est au zénith